[Music]
[Applause]
fure but I had to do it it's I exactly
you understand it would have been two
seconds
ler let's night have one
job ex do it
are
[Music]
[Applause]
I
[Music]
Le
[Applause]
[Music]
SC for
a
[Laughter]
do
[Music]
some you don't want to be
[Applause]
good evening welcome to the table my
name is James pronounce he and him and
uh whether you're you're in person or
online I want to extend a very warm
welcome to you uh especially to our
mothers U happy Mother's Day you know uh
I ow my mother want gratitude I was a
spirited child so T our mothers Happy
Mother's Day
we have a few announcements uh Memorial
Day service there will be no service on
Sunday May 26 the Sunday Memorial Day
Weekend each year we take two Sundays
off to give our volunteers break and
this is one of the two our normal
service will resume the following Sunday
June 2nd then we have potet senior
Sunday Sunday June 2nd we'll be
celebrating our gradic High School
seniors with a popu meal after our
Sunday evening service sign up to bring
a dish using the QR code of on the
screens summer same the DAT our
wonderful table kids team is busy
planning this year's summer R event for
Friday and Saturday June 21st and 22nd
if you have kids going into kindergarten
or finishing sixth grade that would like
to come play learn and grow in love for
Jesus and others this summer please save
the date on your calendars and be
watching for more information and
signups in the coming
weeks in addition to it being Mother's
Day we're we're celebrating Ascension
Sunday and um you know I was
contemplating on Words that would be
appropriate for Ascension Sunday and it
kept coming back around to words that I
learned when I grew up um St Teresa of
ailla wrote some words that you know
even to this day resonate strongly with
me and I thought I would share those
with you
um if we could take a moment to you know
turn off our cell phones and quietly
listen to these words
Christ has no
body but
yours no hands no feet on Earth but
yours your eyes yours are the eyes with
which he looks compassion on this world
yours are the feet with which he walks
to do good your yours are the hands with
which He blesses all the world yours are
the hands yours are the feet yours are
the eyes you are his body Christ has no
body now but yours no hands no feet on
Earth but yours your yours are the eyes
with it which he looks compassion on
this world Christ has no body body now
on Earth but
yours thank you
James if you guys would stand with
us we're going to get started with good
God so you guys sing along
[Music]
be
still be still my soul Be Still My
Soul be still and know that my God is
here be still my soul Be Still My Soul
be still know that my God is here all
that I need to know is this you are a
good God the maker of heaven calls me
his you are a good God your heart beats
in my CH you are a good God all that I
have to do is you are a good
God I won't be afraid
won't be
afraid I won't be afraid my God is here
he'll make a way he will make a way he
will make a way he will make a way my
God is here all that I need to know is
this you are a good God the maker of
heaven calls me you are a good God and
your heart beats in my chain you are a
good God all that I have to do is RA you
are a good
[Music]
god let's sing you gave me your eyes you
gave me your eyes you gave me your heart
your spirit flows through my veins you
your spirit flows through my veins again
gave me your eyes you gave me your heart
your spirit flows through my veins you
your spirit flows through my veins and
you gave me your eyes you gave me your
heart you had a plan right from the
start and I know who I am cuz I know who
you are you are good good all that I
need to know is
the maker of heav calls
me and sing that again all that I need
to know is this you are a good God the
maker of heaven calls me you are
a and your heart beats in my chest you
are a
good all that I have to do is rest you
are a good good God you are a good God
you are a good god oh you are a good
good you are a good God you are a good
God you are a good
God all right kids before we dismiss you
to your classrooms before we do that we
want to honor the moms that are in this
room so we're all standing right now so
I was going to say moms will you stand
but you know what I mean you're already
doing that so if you wouldn't mind maybe
raising your hand if you have been a
part of a mothering Journey a motherhood
journey in your lifetime We Have Allison
over here holding some tulips and we
would just like to honor you guys
whether your kids are here or not would
you just raise your hands and kids would
you guys go grab a flower and pass it
out to these moms who are with us
today e
thank you kiddo so
much once once we've passed out our
flowers you guys are welcome to go to
the door and meet your teachers and they
will take you to your
classrooms and as they exit and make
their way to their classes um I just I
have a reading that we wanted to share
with you um I did not write it but the
woman who did the first time I read this
I just felt like it was so appropriate
because motherhood can look so different
for each one of us um and it can be
beautiful and it can be painful and
sometimes it can be Elusive and um so we
just want to honor
the many different paths that motherhood
can take and you may be sitting here
today wishing that you were a mom or you
may be here having been a mom and it
being a very hard Road and we just want
you to know that you're not alone
whatever that Journey looks like and
you're welcome here in this space this
is called a tribute to
mothers to those who gave birth this
year to their first child we celebrate
with you to those who are in the
trenches with little ones every day and
where the badge of food stains we
appreciate you to those who experienced
loss through miscarriage failed adoption
running away or the loss of a child we
mourn with you to those who walk the
hard path of infertility fraught with
pokes prods tears and disappointment we
walk with you forgive us when we say
foolish things we don't mean to make
this harder than it
is to those who are fostered moms Mentor
moms and spiritual moms we need you to
those who have warm and close
relationships with your children we
celebrate with you and to those who have
disappointment and heartache and
distance with your children we sit with
you to those who lost their mothers this
year we grieve with
you to those who experienced abuse at
the hands of your own mother we
acknowledge your
experience to those who lived through
driving tests medical tests and overall
testing of motherhood we are better for
having you in our midst to those who are
single and long to be married and
mothering your own children we mourn
that life has not turned out the way
that you longed for it to be to those
who stepparent we walk with you on these
complex
paths to those who envisioned lavishing
love on grandchildren yet that dream is
not to be we grieve with you to those
who will have emptier nests in the
upcoming years we grieve and rejoice
with you to those who place children up
for adoption we commend you for the
selflessness and remember how you hold
that child in your
heart and to those who are pregnant with
new life both expected and surprising we
anticipate with you this Mother's Day we
walk with you mothering is not for the
faint of heart and we have real Warriors
in our midst and today we remember
[Music]
you you are
here move moving in our
midst I worship
you I worship
you you are
here working in this
place I worship
you I worship
you you are here
moving in our
midst I worship
you I worship
you you are
here working in this
place I worship
you I worship
you you are way maker mirac work promise
keep light in the darkness my God that
is who you are sing that again you are
way maker Miracle work promise keep
light in the darkness my God that is who
you
are you are
here touching every
heart I worship
you I worship
[Music]
you you are
here healing every
heart I worship
you I worship
you you are
here turnning lives
around I worship
you I worship
you you are
[Applause]
here mending every
heart I worship
you I worship
you you are way maker Miracle work
promise keep light in the darkness my
God that is who you
are you are way maker Miracle Worker
promise keeper light in the darkness my
God that is who you are let's do it one
more time you are way maker Miracle
Worker promise keeper
light in the darkness my God that is who
you
are that is who you
[Music]
are even when I don't see it you're
working even when I don't feel it you're
working never stop you never stop
working even when I don't see it you're
working even though I don't feel it
you're working never stop never stop
working never stop never stop working
even when I don't feel it you're working
you never stop you never stop working
never stop never stop working even when
I don't see it you're working even when
I don't feel it you're working never
stop never stop working never stop you
never stop working way maker Miracle
Worker promise keeper light in the
darkness my God that is who you
are way maker Miracle Worker promise
keeper light in the darkness my God that
is who you
are that is who you
are you are way maker Miracle Worker
promise keeper light in the darkness my
God that is who you are
you are way maker Miracle Worker promise
keeper light in the
darkness my God that is who you
are is
[Music]
is so
good is so
[Music]
good
God is so
good she so
good
to
[Music]
me she she cares for
me she cares for
me
she cares for
me she's so
good
for
me I love her
I love
[Music]
her
I love her
so she's so
good
to
me and
she loves me
[Music]
so
she loves me
so she's so
good
to God is so
God is is so
good
God is so
[Music]
good
God is so
good she's so
good to
God we do believe that regardless of
what we have faced what Journey we are
currently
on that you are a good god leading us
forward that you see us and know us and
walk with
us just like you said in the New
Testament like a mother hen gathers the
chicks under her wings and brings them
in you gather us back back
together in our waywardness in our
confusion in our
doubt in our
pain you tuck Us
in the same way that you hemmed Us in
before and behind before we took a
breath God you now are still doing that
good work Heming us into your
story helping us find our path
towards your heart towards your
love God would we feel closer to you now
than we have
before would we see the areas where your
hand is at work even when we don't feel
it even when we can't see it clearly God
we choose to believe that you are still
doing a good work in
us thank you for meeting us where we are
and for continuing to call us forward in
Jesus name
amen would you guys welcome the people
around you and then Brett will'll get us
started on our message
well Grace and
peace it is so good to be with you all
so so good and uh that includes as
always those join us online love you
lots you're not forgotten and uh anyone
here tonight who is new thank you thanks
for being Among Us and uh I know it can
just it can be a lot coming into a new
space new people all that and uh
sometimes there's even you know
religious uh well it's commonly referred
to as Church hurt although sometimes
it's just downright spiritual trauma
just a it's a real problem and uh and so
coming into this space um we're really
really glad that you're you're here so
yeah so thank you um and uh and also for
me happy Mother's Day to anyone I didn't
catch he was coming in the doors um so
we're in a season right now in the
church calendar called Easter time so
you know we spent this whole season
preparing for like the day of the Cross
and holy week and all that and now On
The Backs side um we spend a whole
season uh celebrating Easter and
Resurrection Life so we're in the series
um titled practicing Resurrection um
we're just kind of going through the
book of Acts and certain passages and
such that uh just describe how the early
church you know expressed uh the
resurrection because it's it really is
it's something to embody to live you
know there's uh um I don't know like a
whole ology a whole way of being that
comes from the hope of Resurrection uh
so we're kind of in the tail end though
of this this series um because uh as
James mentioned earlier it is Ascension
Sunday so you can tell we're kind of
transitioning key moments in in the Life
of Christ and now it's you know we're
Ascension and the next week is Pentecost
and then we're into like new series it's
uh known as ordinary time and kind of uh
some different things so um the title of
my message this week is ascending and
participating ascending and
participating our text is from Acts
chapter 1 verses 1- 11 which reads um in
my former book Theophilus so this is
Luke who of course wrote the Gospel
of Luke y'all are on it all right just
I'm just checking I'm just checking so
in his former book The Gospel of Luke
now he's writing acts so he he's writing
this to a guy named theopus I wrote
about all that Jesus began to do and to
teach until the day he was taking uh he
was taken up to heaven after giving
instructions through the Holy Spirit to
the apostles he had chosen after his
suffering he presented himself to them
and gave them many convincing proofs
that he was alive he appeared to them
over a period of 40 days and spoke about
the kingdom of God on one occasion while
he was eating with them he gave them
this command do not leave Jerusalem but
wait for the gift my father promised
which you have heard me speak about for
John baptized with water but in a few
few days you will be baptized with the
Holy Spirit then they gathered around
him and asked him Lord are you at this
time going to restore the kingdom to
Israel he said to them it is not for you
to know the times or dates the father
has set by his own authority and by the
way that truth continues to this day as
everyone's trying to guess when will he
return and then there's you know all
these predictions and Ridiculousness and
you write out a big fat juicy check my
Ministry and and I'll tell you the day
and time you know it's like all this
trash all over religious television so
all right so he pretty clearly said nope
you're not going to but you will receive
power when the Holy Spirit comes on you
and you will be my Witnesses in
Jerusalem and all Judea and Samaria and
to the ends of the Earth you can kind of
see the concentric circles there it's
Jerusalem and it's kind of working out
even to the ends of the Earth after he
said this he was taken up before their
very eyes and a cloud hid him from their
sight they were looking intently up into
the sky as he was going when suddenly
two men dressed in white Stood Beside
them men of Galilee they said why do you
stand here looking into the sky the same
Jesus who has been taken from you into
heaven will come back in the same way
you have seen him go into
heaven so growing up I uh I honestly I
can't recall ever hearing a sermon on
the ascend ition of Jesus I don't know
if that was because I was just a bad
listener or if it was because there was
just no sermon on that really um you
know we didn't necessarily follow the
church calendar and all that so I don't
know maybe that was it uh and I wonder I
kind of suspect it's the latter uh and I
I wonder if that's because just in
general we kind of find this whole you
know idea just a little bit maybe just a
little bit uh strange you know uh I mean
we think of like CH coming Among Us in
the Incarnation we get that Christ um
crucified we get that Christ resurrected
Easter yeah yes you know Christ
ascended we're like I don't know it's
kind of strange you know um and I I
think it it might be a little bit of the
result of the the almost
cartoonish way we envision this like I
don't know about you but like when I was
a kid you know envisioning not even kid
just even in my adult years until I
started to study and reflect on it more
um I envisioned Jesus is like a it's
like a he was like a cruise missile you
know
just just shot you know I mean Just sh
like slow moving cruise missile you know
just G like a slow motion Cruise Missle
stuff maybe more like a a space shuttle
launch maybe that's more the image you
know
TR and and then I took this very you
know literally
and in fact I remember reading in my I
was right in the middle of
deconstruction I was reading all sorts
of theologians and I came across a guy
very very um kind of liberal Theologian
named John Shelby Spong I think is how
you say it and uh he's quite a character
um and he was he kind of believed like
Christians really can't believe in the
Ascension anymore that was kind of one
of his because of our what's his
cosmology like the way the things we
understand about the universe you know
um so it was basically this idea of like
cruise missile Jesus you know he's like
well we know now the Galaxy you know or
the not just the Galaxy the universe
it's it's huge Beyond a reckoning there
is no shooting up into heaven you know
like if you just keep going eventually
you'll reach heaven you'll bump it you
know or something like now we know I
mean if this is if if you interpret in
this way well GE even after 2,000 years
Jesus is still he's somewhere in the
Milky Way galaxy you know what I mean
just kind
of just he keeps going you know
eventually uh this of course is where I
dis agree with old John Shelby spun
because I think this is a it's a
cartoonish way to think of it I mean
even the text mentions how Jesus is
hidden from their sight by a cloud you
know so in other words the idea isn't
that he's shot off and eventually he'll
just bump into heaven you know uh even I
heard silly stories of people like um
the first like or early astronauts and
folks going you know and like oh nope
God's not up here you know it's kind of
this cartoonish way of thinking about
God EV and all right so um so instead
the the the image is
um is is one where the the mysterious um
spiritual body of Jesus it's about a
passing from one dimension into
another um and and so in other words to
kind of even start to get a grasp of
what the Ascension is all about we're
going to have to leave what's known um
as like our our kind of philosophical
materialism meaning the idea that all
that is is just you know what I mean
just is what you see what you know um
material matter that that's all that is
because then you can't understand the
Ascension because then it's just matter
shooting off in the air and just
traveling through the galaxies or
something you know it just doesn't make
any sense so we you we've got to kind of
leave that that materialist imagination
behind which is strange how even as
Christians we can you know we're kind of
swimming in in secular wat so speak in
in life and uh we just take in certain
assumptions about the world and and it's
assumptions like that that kind of
render the Ascension just silly you know
me just cartoonish and like what is
going on here um but we got to leave
that that assumption behind um because
in other words like bodies bodies are
more
mysterious uh than we often think you
know I'm not literally just like the
brute fact of me is not only what you
see right here these eyes this
skin that's like that is what the the
church fathers and mothers would have
called um my animal body it's kind of
strange language but they just meant
like the the the physical stuff the
blood and the guts and you know what I
mean it's that part of us um but there
is more and it's not about being unod or
like you know there's the body and then
there's something else it's it's more
like no there's a a spiritual body um
this
other aspect to us and it's that logic
that's what you have to kind of
understand and then apply right to to
Christ um and and so we have to kind of
ask what if that kind of philosophical
that materialistic way of viewing the
universe and all of creation and such
what if that's just wrong and what if um
we are more than simple matter and what
if there there are actually invisible
depths
to you and I that would just Boggle the
Mind beautiful I like that um for our
online viewers it's raining I don't know
if they can I don't know if they're here
I'm just like beautiful they're just
like what is going
[Laughter]
[Music]
on
so and this is why for example Jesus can
say um I promise that I will be with you
to the very end of the
age right and and really mean that that
he is with us but he's with us
differently than we might have imagined
it we might sum it up by saying Christ
us Sins Not to create an
absence but to become a presence that
will fill us and all creation
this this is about um the
the the expanding spiritual body of
Christ and this is why the Ascension of
Jesus it's not like a cause you'll
notice even in the text it's not a cause
for grief in a sense of bereavement and
loss like in other words Jesus doesn't
say and I must go you know and they
don't burst into tears you know I mean
that's not the story it's not and the
disciples began to weep for they knew
they would never see him again you know
that's not the story instead it's it's
something
different it's it's a um well the way
Theologian Graham Ward puts it in his um
book cities of God he says it like this
the logic of the
Ascension is the logic of
birthing not dying or a continuation of
the logic of opening up the withdrawal
of the body of Jesus must be understood
in terms of Christ creating within
himself a womb within which in Christ
the church will expand and creation be
recreated that's kind of the that's the
image here now again if you think of it
in purely materialistic physical terms
this makes no sense because bodies again
we think of a what body it's just right
here this doesn't expand or I can't
incorporate you all into my very being
you know it's like what do you but
remember it's it's a spiritual body it's
more
mysterious different than we might um
expect now I should say Ward gives me an
incredibly uh fortunate metaphor here
because of course it's both Mother's Day
and Ascension Sunday and here in this
quote we have like right the two ideas
meeting um because what he's naming here
is that the Ascension of Jesus it's not
an ending right but it's actually a
beginning it's not the idea that Jesus
can just finally well he just can't wait
to ditch us
and get off this godforsaken planet and
then one day you know evacuate all of us
off this godforsaken planet like no
that's not the idea instead um it's it's
that well he knows that the work that he
has done in his physical material body
that that that season that's come to a
close and now it's time for the work he
does in and through his spiritual body
that that will continue in us through
the holy SP spirit so this then leads to
another kind of unique idea that you've
probably heard but maybe you're hearing
it differently now um which is this the
Ascension shows us how it is that the
church is now the body of
Christ um that's you've heard this idea
right and it's kind of a strange one
like we even have this in our language
you know of uh like you've maybe if
you've been in church circles for a
while you've heard people say something
like so as a body we're going to be
going to the soup kitchen on Friday
night and so we do we hope that you all
can be there like um you know or
whatever like oh our body it's been
going through a really hard time we lost
so and so and so and so passed away you
know it's just it's been a kind of
Grievous time for the body but we're
believing and you know and we just kind
of throw this out here but of course to
like an
outsider it just sounds completely Lun
you know what I mean like body why are
yall keep referring to yourselves as a a
a body body it's so weird you know a
body in fact I've been a part of
churches that kind of wanted us to ditch
that language precisely because
Outsiders would come in and they're just
like this is weird these Christians are
you know
body but I don't think we should ditch
it uh as we'll get to later I think
there's actually some real ramifications
for why this matters but but for now
I'll just name I think it's actually
kind of a beautiful notion that we all
all together we are somehow in
Christ
and and and it's like he's he
incorporating Us in and and now we're
connected not only to Christ but deeply
to one another the way Ephesians 1:22
through 23 puts it says and God placed
all things under Christ's feet and
appointed him to be head over everything
for the church which is his body
the fullness of him who fills everything
in every way and of course it's the
Ascension right the spiritual expanding
body that makes this
possible and again here's the beautiful
part of this like just think of this
that means that you all are in a very
real sense you are in
Christ like you again we throw that
language around and I think we've just
taken it almost p as metaphor you know
or just sort of like a nice notion I'm
in Christ you know uh and not really
thinking like what that means like no no
like kind of mean that seriously you
know again not necessarily physically
not in that way but in this kind of
spiritual but very real sense you are in
Christ which also means like it's this
weird thing Christ is in you like you
are like Christ is um so fully
identified with each of us
in ways that would like Boggle our mind
like I think of the way like a mother is
so identified with like the child you
know in her womb that it's hard to even
tell medically like where does the the
mother begin and the child begin and you
know one end and the other begin like
it's it's kind of because they're like
within you know that's sort of that's
kind of the image here it's right as gr
W alluded to it's it's Christ is like
Mak this
womb within which we're all being
Incorporated which means if you think
about it like I think again we kind of
think of like Jesus as like well Jesus
was like you know he was uh this male
and Jewish and you kind of had this
identity but now right Christ through
this spiritual body you could say is now
more than that like for example you
could say Christ is because you all are
in Christ right Christ is
straight but Christ is also
queer Christ is masculine and
feminine uh Christ is able-bodied and
terribly
sick the spiritual body of
Christ is both poor and well off is
white and black and
brown Christ is mentally ill Christ is
lonely I mean it sounds sort of
scandalous and strange I hope it strikes
you as a little bit strange because I
want you to I want to get you thinking
about like how to say Christ like we are
in
Christ is to really utter
something I I think really profound
maybe it sounds like complete gibberish
and what you know whatever u i I think
there's really something um incredibly
profound about this so Christ has so has
chosen us so closely align himself with
each and every one of us that when
we see you we in some sense
see who
Christ there's a a quote from um Gregory
of
Nissa uh he said she who sees the church
looks directly at
Christ she who sees the church looks
directly directly at
Christ see there is a space within
Christ for you for
us so don't say like
oh I'm I'm distant I'm I'm far off I'm
like far off from God you know I'm like
no no
no you're much closer than you think
like how how far off is a a mother from
the child in her
womb not very far off real
close real
close now I uh I could imagine someone
kind of saying or wondering like ah is
this just though kind of is this all a
little bit out there you know it's
little woo woo Pastor Brett's going all
woo woo today and a little little m
mycal
um and and maybe even feeling what was
that that's that Old Devil she said like
my grandmother used to say That's That
Old Devil
talking I like that yeah so um like I
mentioned I do I think it matters like I
I I think there's something really
powerful here um but I can imagine
someone saying well let's talk of
participate you know it's invisible and
like how does this you know how does
this work does it even really matter um
but here's the thing I think it seems
that human
beings have um some sort of really deep
almost innate longing to participate in
something um bigger than
ourselves do you maybe agree with that
like there's kind of a we don't do well
as just like little isolated people you
know we want to we want to kind of you
know
participate and um it's interesting to
me at precisely the same moment that the
church I think in a way is sort of
losing this notion of us participating
in the the body of Christ as like a
really like a re like a reality that at
that same moment um something like
Christian nationalism for example is on
the rise hopefully if I lost you in this
first 15 minutes I just woke you up
um because I really do I think this
matters like how this plays out um
because in other words we have this kind
of
longing and we we and so what happens
like Christian nationalism becomes a a
parody a a sort of like cheap
imitation of the True Body of Christ
it's like a a false Body of Christ a
sort of warped and twisted understanding
right it's in essence um its
americanism with all of its Theology and
values and such you know and its own
kind of church fathers George Washington
you know or whatever and go to the
Washington DC and see this interesting
phallic symbol of the Washington
Monument I mean the whole like it's like
this whole mythology you know so it's
it's in essence
americanism with a Jesus hood ornament
kind of stuck on the front you know a
Jesus bumper steer kind of slapped on
there
uh but you scratch the surface of it and
it's it's not
resonating um much with with who Christ
actually is um but but what's but what's
going on there why is it on the rise why
is it so popular because even in a
secular age oh we're longing for the
Transcendent we're hungry for something
bigger than ourselves and honestly you
know kind of the political in the state
like that's in a secular age that's if
you're going to kind of try to ditch God
that's about as big and epic as you can
get like that that's it right and so
what happens that that kind of arises
because it becomes very alluring for
folks we become drawn to it drawn to
what this
participation in a broader
body but but here's the thing I think
American nationalism it's not only a
dead end it's actually a a religiously
and political um a very dangerous dead
end precisely because the politics of
this world inevitably becomes about a
power over a power against right
Christian nationalism just skewed
towards a certain Christian
imperialism right a kind of a a
dominance a a body that um doesn't just
kind of gently incorporate and invite
and welcome but a body that sort of um
commands get in or it's bad for you you
know it's a It's that kind of power uh
Graham Ward again speaking of the True
Body of Christ he put it like this he
said there's no room for Christian
imperialism Crusades in the name of the
Triune love
misconceive the kosis that means
self-giving um self outpouring of that
love that love is poured out eternally
on behalf
of not against you hear the difference
there between the two bodies on behalf
of not
against you see Christian nationalism
and imperialism it always ends up being
against
over and against rather than for and on
behalf of and I believe this like this
is a
word that the church broader than even
just the table that we need right now we
we need to remember this so This
Ascension Sunday what I want to invite
you to to do is to um
resist these false bodies of Christ to
to resist the lure of so-called
Christian nationalism and instead give
yourself to participation in the True
Body of Christ the one who always gives
on behalf of others never against them
in the name of the Father the Son holy
spirit amen so as we uh as we come to
the table of the Lord tonight as we take
in the body of Christ and the bread the
blood of Christ in the wine I I hope you
can see that that's communion itself is
a picture of everything I've been
talking about it's like an icon it's you
what do you do you take in
Christ as and in the same way Christ
takes you in right it's this kind of
giving and receiving this this um
participation and mixing of of bodies so
um as you participate I want you to kind
of come in that that mindset as you
commit to the True Body of Christ so the
way we'll do this is we'll just go row
by row um we practice what's called an
open table so if you're here tonight and
something within you you want to
participate you want to be connected to
Christ in this way then you are welcome
to do that um if but if you'd rather not
that's okay too there's no there's no
pressure um no pressure to do that you
should know the red is wine the white is
grape juice and then finally you can
just um partake whenever and however
you'd like some folks like take right
away others like to kneel or or however
but no one will lead you through the
exact moment of taking so this is the
table not of the
church but of the
Lord and it's made ready for those who
love him and for those who want to love
him more so come you who have much Faith
you who have little you who have been
here often and you who have not been
here long you who have tried to follow
this week you feel like you failed
um because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you and it's his will that
those who want to meet him should meet
them
here
e
e e
[Music]
as we close out with this final song you
guys are welcome to stand and sing these
words with
us and let's invite God to be a part of
each each one of us and to see to see
him in our lives in our hearts in our
actions
[Music]
as
iise strength of
God go
before lift
me as a w
Eyes Of
[Music]
God look
upon be
[Music]
my as I
wait as I
wait heart of God
[Music]
satisfy and
sustain as I
hear voice of
[Music]
God lead me
on be my
gu be my
gu above and below me
before and behind me in every eye that
sees me Christ me all around me above
and below me before and behind me in
every eye that sees me Christ be all
around me
as I
go hand of
[Music]
God Mighty
face by my
side as I
rest Breath of
God fall
upon bring me
peace bring me peace
above and below me before and behind me
in every ey sees me Christ be all around
me above and below me before and behind
me in every eye that sees me Christ me
all around me yeah w
wo
wo Christ be all around
me
woo
W Christ be all around
me your life your life
your dead your blood was shed for every
moment every moment your life your death
your blood was shame for every
moment every moment your life your dead
your
sh for every
moment every moment your life your death
your blood was shed for every
moment every
moment above and below me before and
behind me
in every eye that sees me Christ be all
around me above and below me before and
behind me in every ey Se Me Christ be
all around me above and below me before
and behind me in every eye that sees me
Christ be All Around Me Above and Below
me before and
behind in every eye that sees me Christ
me all around
me
wo
[Music]
wo PR be all around me yeah w
W wo
wo chist be all around
[Music]
me thank you so much for joining us this
evening if you're new we would love for
you to fill out a card at the table on
your way out or just scan the QR code on
the screen to fill out the online
visitor card that will allow us to
follow up with you answer questions you
might have and say thank you for
visiting if you are in need of prayer or
just general support come find me after
the service I would like to be there for
you however I can here at the table we
are committed to creating an inclusive
Christ centered community that touches
lives and generosity is a key component
of that mission if you if you'd like to
join us in supporting this work
financially you can scan the QR code on
the screens or out in the lobby or go to
our website at the
tx.org
[Music]
all right let me send you into the week
with this blessing you can hold out your
hands in a posture of receiving or just
open your heart to these
words you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true on your best day and
this is true on your worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with it's yet to be determined highs and
lows go build with the assurance that
you are loved you are worthy and go
filled with God's holy spirit and a
desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with be blessed have
a good week we hope to see you here next
Sunday at 5:00 P PM good night
[Music]
oh